okay let's go to the caller from the 262
area code caller from - 6 - who are you
where you calling from I'm Zachary Hayes
from Milwaukee Wisconsin great and we're
not on speakerphone are we and no okay
and whatever's on in the background if
you are able to turn it down it would be
really great yeah yeah all right well
what's going on
Zachary um so a lot of my friends are
right-wingers and I try and tell them
that I support Bernie Sanders and they
always seem to think that I support
conversation and I always play the
videos that playin clips of independent
news and that was - oh you would just
watch to get that I never claimed let me
see an X nothing of the sort
I don't know what to do there because
they always think that Bernie Sanders
the communist or well I would just ask
them to put put that if they're making
the assert so you know I would point out
communism is state control of Industry
right I mean communism has a very very
the state controls the means of
production can you give me one example
of a communist policy from Bernie
Sanders and just put it on them you know
I mean honestly it sounds like you
really shouldn't even be talking
politics with these people sounds like
an exercise you're like yeah they go to
a single-payer health care that's like a
social democracy that's not a social
that not communism no I mean with they
know that I would say is Denmark a
communist country is Sweden a communist
country get out there and make a look at
the size of the country though compared
well but that's that so then they're
moving the goalposts then you have to
point out you are moving from an
argument about whether single-payer is
communism to an argument about whether
single-payer can work in a country of
300 million people like the United
States they've moved the goalposts and
you've got to point that out right away
yeah yeah thank you all right no problem
yeah those conversations I try not to
have those conversations because they're
you know as you can tell pretty
problematic